hi everyone I'm Marsh Gay Harden hi
everyone I'm Skyler Aston and I'm in
CVS's new series so help me Todd today
I'm taking a quiz with BuzzFeed where I
find out if I can cut it as a private
eye
I play Margaret Wright I'm a successful
attorney who brings on my son Todd as a
private investigator for my Law Firm
this is going to be so great for you I
play Todd a private detective who goes
to work for his Uber successful lawyer
mom to get his life back on track
it's your first day on the job and you
have to stake out a subject what do you
pack a comfy clothes B plenty of snacks
C water bottles for bathroom breaks and
D camera or E all of the above all of
the above I have only shot scenes where
I've done stakeouts and I know for a
fact you need all of those things
you need to track down someone's
biological father I've done that before
and all you have is his first name and
the last place your client saw okay it
was first name the last place requires
that what's the first thing you do to
find them a go to the courthouse to look
for records B social media C find the
client and see where they go D drive to
the last place the client saw him I'm
gonna say you followed him you followed
them I think it's either b or d but I'm
gonna go with b hey
what types of records are not made
public by the Freedom of Information Act
that's a good one a military records B
FBI records Congressional records D
Social Security records I don't know FBI
let's go with B FBI records I feel like
they're too covert to be public
really hard why do we start with this
whatever happened like what makes you
think of fall okay
um true or false true or false it's
getting it's getting intense here it's
lightning round stuff partial
fingerprints are admissible as evidence
in court this is a good one false it's
only partial they're not admissible
right I'm gonna go false it's true
partial fingerprints are admissible but
not usually enough to convict or prove
someone's guilt what device is used to
record the numbers dialed for outgoing
calls a a bug b a pen register c a wire
Dia hot mic
it's not C or D it's not a bug it's not
a bug a bug is when you're listening a
pen registers I don't know maybe you can
poke things with the pen let's go with B
pen register because I have no idea what
that is and it seems like something like
that but it might be a it's a head
register I don't know what it is it
records all numbers called from a phone
line never heard of it I'll be using it
in the next episode of
so what have we learn today people that
was exhausting I just guess you wouldn't
really trust a TV Doctor to operate you
wouldn't trust a TV lawyer to get you
out of a of a crime and you wouldn't
trust a TV private investigator to
investigate because we just played them
on TV however very convincingly if you
want to see more action watch so
nine at nine eight Central on CBS and
Paramount Plus
[Music]